le trac l'ont fait partie des solutions
retenues par un certain nombre de pays
donc nous avons fait le choix de
travailler en lien avec eux pour
regarder ses solutions
je suis convaincu que si elles
permettent de lutter contre le virus
et si évidemment elle respecte les
libertés individuelles
c'est un outil qui sera retenu est
soutenu par l'ensemble des français
cela n'est pas la culture française je
fais confiance aux français pour que
nous n'ayons pas à mettre en place ces
systèmes qui au fond atteignent la
liberté individuelle de chacun pour être
efficace donc ce n'est pas un sujet sur
lequel nous travaillons
[Musique]
on
oui
[Musique]